foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-511
object class Euclid
special containment procedures
when an instance of scp-511 is
identified the affected residents shall
be quarantined and will receive the next
sequential site designation
accepting one main entrance sites
hosting scp-511 will have all points of
possible entry or exit permanently
sealed with appropriate building
materials the main entrance will remain
locked at all times entry is permitted
to Foundation personnel with written
authorization from Level 3 or higher all
scp-511 Sites will be equipped with
remote monitoring equipment allowing for
24-Hour surveillance and a continual
tracking of the numbers of scp-511-1
inhabiting the site
at all times one class D Personnel will
be resident in the site personnel with
this assignment are exempt from monthly
termination for the duration of the
assignment candidates for this
assignment shall be exclusively drawn
from a population of post-menopausal
women with a global clinical dementia
rating of two or greater
note due to the exclusive nature of this
population 05 has approved recruiting
from local hospice and or nursing homes
if necessary reference incident i-511-11
the population of scp-511 within a site
must remain within an optimal range of
50 to individuals below this range adult
Fearless domesticus should be introduced
to the site to increase population to
minimum levels if population exceeds
individuals it must be called
immediately nascp 511-1 found outside
the containment site shall be euthanized
and the remains incinerated
any biological material leaving the
containment side for testing will be
handled in accordance with the standard
protocols for a level 4 biohazard all
specimens are incinerated after testing
is complete before coming in contact
with any material from the containment
site personnel must be inoculated for
influenza hepatitis A Hepatitis B
tetanus tick-borne Encephalitis and
full medical workups are mandatory on a
bi-weekly basis for personnel working
with scp-511
description
instances of scp-511 typically occur
within residential structures with a
block or stone foundation that includes
a basement or crawl space all attempts
to remove an instance of scp-511 from
such a residence have proved ineffective
reference interview 511 a
scp-511 is always found associated with
a colony of feral Fearless domesticus
common domestic cats members of this
Colony are designated scp-511 1.
scp-511 is a massive biological matter
taking the form of a large feline often
with extra limbs eyes mouths or other
organs it is typically coated with dirt
blood and fecal matter making its fur
appear black despite its actual coloring
tests have shown scp-511's fur to
actually be a random Patchwork of
various feline coat patterns colors and
length
scp-511's mass varies from 10 kilograms
to over 50 kilograms roughly in
proportion to the number of scp-511-1 in
the associated Colony the tissue that
makes up this mass consists primarily of
the bodies of deceased scp-511-1 the
portion of scp-511 that does not
comprised scp-511-1 consists of other
biomass small rodents various plant
materials insects and insect larvae
black mold and human
incorporation of dead tissue into
scp-511 does not appear to slow the
normal process of Decay different areas
of scp-511 undergo different stages of
biodegradation at any given time
some areas show little more than
lividity while other areas may show
active carrion insect infestation and
some areas may even show liquefaction of
tissues
note researchers have described scp-511
making a purring sound tests have shown
this sound does not originate with
scp-511 but is actually The Sound of
Insects most often blowflies trapped
within its Mass Dr A
scp-511 prefers to inhabit dark spaces
with a relatively high humidity such as
old basements and crawl spaces it will
continually scavenge in its immediate
area for new biomass to incorporate into
itself displacing and expelling matter
that has decayed past mechanical
usefulness
examples of scp-511-1 resemble ordinary
Fearless domesticus that have undergone
extreme neglect they display a body
condition score of 2 or 1. regardless of
the amount of food available
ulcerated skin is common as our
parasitic infestations tumors and
various viral and bacterial infections
scp-511-1 are known carriers of a
particularly virulent strain of
a typical scp-511-1 shows no interest in
grooming itself and has patchy and
matted fur it is unclear to what extent
the physical condition of an scp-511-1
is a result of the influence of scp-511
and to what extent it is due to
sub-optimal living conditions
several observations have been made of
an scp-511-1 retrieving biomass from
elsewhere and bringing it to scp-511 to
be incorporated
addendum one incident report of
containment breach at site 511
document i511 11. Personnel involved
d-7856 male subject 35 years of age
date 08 27 19.
location site 511
Evergreen Way California
description
after determining that a permanent human
Presence at an scp-511 site results in
moderation of aggression in scp-511-1
containment protocol is updated to
require d-class Personnel to reside
on-site in the event the original
homeowner is deceased six months after
this policy is established
d-7856 is assigned to site 511 as
expected within a week aggression levels
of scp-511-1 toward Foundation Personnel
lessened considerably
16 days after being assigned to site 511
d-7856 begins showing signs of increased
aggression verbally abusing Foundation
personnel and engaging in superficial
vandalism of site 511
d-7856 is reprimanded
18 days into his assignment
d-7856 interferes with a foundation team
by throwing garbage and yelling
obscenities
d-7856 is subdued with a tranquilizer
dart and locked in his quarters
at 27 days
d-7856 begins capturing scp-511-1 and is
only discovered when a foundation
research team enters four routine
specimen collection 48 hours later the
team discovers remains from 37 separate
scp-511-1 collected in the kitchen
bodies are dismembered and show signs
7856's body is discovered in the
basement after an apparent attempt to
site 511 is incinerated as an emergency
containment procedure
okay I think there's something to the
crazy cat lady idea think we need to be
more careful with the class D's on this
one Dr A
addendum 2. interview with agent
Survivor of containment breach at site
511 47.
interview 511 a
interviewed agent
interviewer Dr A
forward agent was sole survivor from
mobile task
assigned to retrieve scp-511 for study
from site 51147 after the death of the
homeowner Mrs B interview takes place at
Saint Hospital in Ohio
playing log now
how are you feeling
like I've had half my face ripped off
how do you think I feel I want to talk
about the containment Bridge
[Applause]
we have some questions of course you do
starting with why there was foreign
matter introduced into the containment
unit
do you have any idea
what we're dealing with why don't you
tell me
we were tasked to retrieve a 40 kilo a
thing with a bsl4 containment unit
you know how big those units are I know
the specifications like logging a
self-propelled washing machine
now I imagine dragging one of those into
one of these places
they already got reduced Mobility from
the Hazmat suit and got 50 kilos of gear
and you're walking into a house that has
two or three decades worth of garbage in
it we have cats angle deep in places
trash bags split open piles of soggy
newspaper and junk mail boxes of clothes
furniture that looked like it exploded
everywhere
eyes everywhere
can we return to the containment unit
we have just high in places
everywhere and space is so tight that we
have to go single
no way a guy in full gear can turn
around and forget the containment unit
one look
a way we can use
you so it was agent idea it was that or
packaged in can't get downstairs so we
beat the unit with the body and pointed
at the basement door according to the
briefing it would be attracted to
Freshly dead biological matter and
scp-511 was attracted to the baited unit
the most
20 minutes of my life listening to that
thing pull itself upstairs
and those cats
watching us
you know how freaky cat eyes look with
night vision equipment
so you captured scp-511.
what happened then we got out as quickly
as we could no one can turn around so we
back out all those eyes watching us
staring you were first out the door last
in first out we all got out from for all
the good it did we thought we pulled it
off but the moment the containment unit
rolled out the door it
they
what happened
to see films of explosive decompression
that's what happened to it
splattered itself all over the insides
of the containment unit
and those cats those
full cats
cats they howled then they rushed us did
you attempt to contain the bridge you're
kidding right two or three hundred of
them not just the door but the windows
dropping on us from the second floor
when I saw
disappear under them I just ran and
locked myself in the van
I'm not proud of that I'm not here to
judge I'm here to determine what
happened so it does not happen again
well you see what happened to me
I was one of them that got locked in
with me
one
if you don't reclassify these things as
ketter you're insane I will be
recommending updates to containment
procedure yeah
updating things there's something else
you need to update
what's that The Briefing was all about
how scp-511 is influencing these cats
that's wrong
how so
scp-511 doesn't influence anything
it's the cats they made scp-511
they made it because they hate
end log
closing statement
agent died three days later from
complications due to blood poisoning
three weeks after Containment Breach a
new incidence of scp-511 was identified
in Ohio
35 kilometers southeast of site 51147
remote biopsies of this new incidence
revealed genetic material identified as
coming from three agents of mobile task
force
it seems that the destruction of scp-511
might only displace it elsewhere
until we better understand the vectors
that propagated
all scp-511 need to be contained in
place
request for reclassification of scp-511
to Qatar is denied
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
James Samba
braided Peach
that loser
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you